one thing i'd asked somebody a long time
ago was how does this
service shazam works and shazam for
those who who don't know
is a service where you can hold your
smartphone up
press a button it listens to a song and
then it tells you who the song is by and
and
you know what the song is called and we
had a discussion
and you've done some research into this
and you'll be able to show us how it
works
yeah well um i have looked into how
they've done it over the years and i'd
imagine the way they're doing it now
is uh vastly more superior than the
original algorithms that people propose
they were doing and obviously we don't
100 know how they're doing it they've
given away some of the information and
then other people
have kind of speculated and written up
their own papers on how things could be
done but
um what i've actually done is written a
working model
kind of like a shazam simulator
which uh when when we were setting up
the zoom call for this i put in the
subject line
shazoom so we're going to call my
service shazoom
it does work i mean i've only got a few
songs that we're going to load into it
and test with but i was going to go
through
how i think that at least the original
version
of shazam worked even if it's not the
same now
fantastic and um i know that you've put
it on a website so people can go and
have a play with it and we'll come to
that in a bit
yeah i know that somebody i spoke to
said oh they must do it with
beats per minute which is you know how
fast or the tempo of the song is it is
that what it's
that's kind of like an emergent property
you will get a certain amount of beat
detection
and other bits and pieces but the first
thing to do is to
run an fft over it's kind of slice the
song into 100 millisecond
chunks what's fft fast fourier transform
um
that's probably one of the most
important bits of the whole
thing and what i'm going to do is give
you the the
quickest and most basic explanation on
what it does
i'm going to give you a pound shop
version of it now or in america
dollar store version of it okay so we've
got a nice little sine wave
which all computer people seem to be
very bad at drawing because we spend
more time typing but
let's say that this here the period
between this is 100
hertz which means 100
times per second that it that it goes
through its cycle right
if you imagine that you had a clock with
a single hand on it
and that clock is spinning around at a
rate so we're going to
imagine we've got this clock and that
hand is going around a particular rate
so
let's say that that clock is totally in
sync
with the sine wave so the sine wave is
100 hertz 100 times per second and the
clock is going around 100 times per
second which may seem fast but for audio
that's very very slow what you'll end up
with is you'll end up with a correlation
with the wave
that's coming in just as a quick recap
when you're sampling on a computer when
you're sampling
a wave effectively you are just taking
a reading of the voltage
the middle of it is zero and above it
you consider positive and below it you
consider negative numbers so
that's all we need to know for this so
what we're going to do
is imagine you've got this clock that's
going around 100 hertz
and the hand is at the top and let's say
we're right at the peak of one of the
waves
so that's going to be the highest bit so
let's say that's that's 100
from the zero point that value is 100.
so in this clock
let's say we're going to plot a point
here at 100
so the distance there between the center
of this clock
and there is going to be a hundred now
as you come down the wave
and you get to the trough at the bottom
halfway through the period
that hand is going to have turned round
to be exactly 180 degrees around the
other way so that hand is now down in
that direction
but of course your number that you're
plotting is a negative number because
you've come back down the other way so
you're plotting in the opposite
direction
so what you'd end up with is the point
on this clock that you're going around
the point would be in exactly the same
pace as it was when it was at the top of
the sine
wave because it's in the opposite
direction now if you have a hundred
hertz sine wave coming in the data
all the all the um the volume levels of
of the the sine wave coming in it's 100
hertz the data's coming in and your
clock's going round 100 hertz
what ends up happening is you can end up
plotting the same point
all the time because it's hitting all
the peaks and all the troughs
and if you've got a sample rate which
you would have which would have many
many more slices than just getting the
peaks and the troughs
what you end up with is a load of other
scattered out noise
and if you take all of those points so
let's say we had a point there and a
point there
and a point there and a point there well
all of those points that are surrounding
it
if you use complex maths basically you
you average it and reduce it down
and the noise will cancel itself out and
you'll be left with a prominent point
on your 2d graph and that prominent
point
will be how loud that particular
frequency you were feeding in
is within that particular signal so if
you were then to
say put in 101 hertz but you've got the
clock going at 100 hertz although you
will get some correlation
it's not going to be as much and then
102 hertz is going to be less
correlation it's going to keep going
down until effectively
it will just turn into noise and all of
those points will cancel each other out
so if you want to find out how much 100
hertz 200 hertz 300 hertz 400 hertz and
you want to keep going
you have to run effectively run a sine
wave through and do a comparison to the
original signal plotting these points
average them down and see what's left at
the end of it
so if you wanted to do it for 100
different frequencies you'd have to do
that 100 times
there are libraries out there that do
this stuff super fast
super reliably and and much better than
i'm ever going to do it but
the whole point of fft is you put in an
audio signal
and you get out the component
frequencies
so for example if you had a sound which
was like a piano so you're playing an a
on a piano
it'll be 440 hertz will be the main
fundamental frequency but then there'll
be harmonics within that and then you'll
get
the octave up at 880 and and and so on
keep doubling the frequencies and
they'll they'll fall off and
it's the mixture of all of those
frequencies together that give you
the sound and it just doesn't sound like
a pure sine wave
so when you combine all of those
different elements that make up
that note those different elements make
the note
sound like it's a specific instrument or
a specific song yeah guitar will have
different harmonics to a piano they'll
also have a different
you know some some instruments will
slowly rise to a peak of a sound some
will come in and be very percussive and
have what's called a transient at the
beginning of it
um so when you have all of these
different sounds
they they're they're a combination of
lots and lots of different sine waves at
different frequencies
and when you put them all together they
produce
one waveform which is a lot more
complicated which is the music you
listen to or the speech you listen to
or whatever and and at fft and furio
transforming
basically is a way to get those
fundamental frequencies
back out of the song so if you've got a
song and you've got loads of different
frequencies and you want to say
do i have 50 hertz playing at this point
do i have 250 hertz playing at this
point
you're effectively running it through
and doing a comparison to a to a raw
250 hertz signal do this clock thing
plot your plot your points and do an
averaging to find out and basically
however far away the point you're left
with is from the center
of the clock is how loud that signal is
within that particular bit of data that
you've given it
and although that does it doesn't matter
in this particular case
sort of where it's offset you know as in
like twelve o'clock
one o'clock two o'clock whatever is
actually also the phase is how the
how the uh how the wave is shifted but
we really don't need to get into that
for the purposes of this
we're just basically getting out what
frequencies are being used and obviously
the more frequencies you want to test
the longer it's going to take to do
so we've got a very complicated waveform
which is
maybe a musical song with a bass and a
drums and guitar and piano and all these
different
things which has become one waveform but
it's an extremely complicated waveform
because it's
made up of all of these different
instruments which in turn
are made up of all these different
harmonics and different
elements we're using fft to
look at a musical track and to pull out
some information about what frequencies
are occurring yeah when we get our song
let me change a change sheet of paper
here
if we have a a song coming in that's
like a complex waveform
what's going to happen with that is that
will be made of
a set of frequencies and we want to get
those out and really all we're
interested in
is between maybe 100 hertz which is
quite low it's not super sub bass but
it's it's low enough that a phone would
be able to pick it up
accurately and then say about 5 000
hertz or 5 kilohertz
which is quite a cutting sort of
frequency that hurts your ears
obviously the higher the frequency the
data the more
intricate data there is in there but the
more noise you're going to have when
you're trying to use a phone to record
something in a
in a loud environment or with some
background noise so what we're trying to
do is pass through this complicated
waveform
and we're really interested in looking
at frequencies
between 100 hertz and 5000 hertz 5k
now an average the songs that i'm
dealing with here are sampled at 48k
which means you can accurately represent
a 24k
signal in reality the way shazam would
do is they downsample that they don't
need huge files with all of that
top end on it i just had them at that so
if you had 24 000 different frequencies
you were looking at with your
you that you got back you would uh you
would end up with 24 000 different
numbers and one for each individual
frequency obviously that would take
way too long so the one that i actually
use if i look at my code here i've got
an fft
size in my javascript at the top here
the fft size is 2048 which i believe
will return
1024 individual frequencies so if you
were to split
up naught to 24 000
divide that by 1024 then you work
out each frequency chunk that it's
looking at so basically we're looking at
about
23 hertz 23.4 hertz
um per slice that we're looking at so
this waveform this complicated song
waveform
is going to have a reading it's going to
have a let's say a figure between
0 and 1 of how loud that is so one is
the loudest possible zero being the
quietest possible
and we're going to have that for 23
hertz
chunks all the way up from zero
to 24 000 hertz and we get that data
back
as an array you'd feed a song through
this system that you just talked about
and effectively pull out that
information pull out that data
yes effectively pull out the data on
each frequency so if there's a lot of
low frequencies if there's a load of
going on you're going to get more stuff
happening in the lower parts of the
array and if you've got a load of top
end stuff happening you're going to get
it in the
the higher the higher elements of the
array
this is what they would do to all the
source music or the originals
is that right yeah so they go through
and get this information out so then
there's another stage beyond that
so once you've got out all this
information so let's say we've got
um all of these different frequency
ranges and at each frequency range we've
got a
effectively a volume level how loud is
it and we'll say for the sake of this
between zero
and one okay so we get out
how loud that is and we then want to
effectively group some of those together
so we want to say well anything that's
within this range
will kind of say this is all one bucket
we call it a bucket
bucket of frequencies right and i
all i'm interested is in this bucket of
frequencies is which one of those
is the loudest one and then i'm just
going to get rid of everything else i
don't care beyond that
so if i've got say 100 hertz
all the way up to 5k 5000 hertz okay so
we've got these six
frequency buckets going up and all i'm
interested is i want one
frequency in the bottom bucket
i want one frequency in the second
bucket i want one frequency in the third
bucket and so on
so that i get the most prominent
frequencies and then effectively with
that i'm going to draw a dot
i'm just gonna call that a point on my
graph in each one so
we should get six dots out maximum of
six dots per slice
and if you have each column as a hundred
milliseconds so every second you're
getting ten columns of this audio
suddenly you've got a nice little graph
with lots of different data points in
slightly
different places and i think the best
thing is we just show it on the screen
just to make it real for people is 100hz
something like a bass guitar
or something like that can you give us a
couple of examples of those
different instruments they don't just
have one frequency spectrum they'll have
a whole
vast range of frequency spectrums and
part of mixing and being an audio
engineer is finding ways of
putting all those together so that they
sound nice and kind of thinking well if
i lose that bit of fruit spectrum off
the guitar then the bass can go in and
take the same space and it's not
not going to interfere and sound
horrible so it doesn't get too muddy
okay
but different instruments will have uh
different areas of the frequency
spectrum that they take up so bass drum
will be right at the bottom and then i'd
say bass guitar just above it and then
you you'd have some snare drum around
200 hertz
you'd have guitars produce a lot of sort
of four or 500 hertz and then vocals can
really kick through it about
you know the prominent frequencies of
sort of 800 to 1000 to
so then it starts getting cutting around
that area and then all that
is happening and the the 4 000 to
8 10 000 hertz range that's where the
prominent frequencies are
obviously a guitar will produce 50 hertz
and it will also be producing
you know 12 000 hertz but it's where the
most
prominent frequencies are for that
instrument and that's that's the
important thing
and generally when you play a note you
will have a thing called a fundamental
so if i was to play that a
at 440 hertz on my guitar it's going to
produce loads of other lower and upper
harmonics
but the most prominent frequency will be
that 440 hertz
and that will be the fundamental and
what we're really looking for
is fundamentals within our frequency
buckets
how do we look at those on the screen
well effectively it's a two-dimensional
graph
you have time along the bottom and you
have frequency
up and actually i say two-dimensional
three-dimensional way because the color
that's actually plotted in those instead
of it being a number you display it as a
color and
and uh traditionally you know blue will
be quiet
and red would be loud or going into the
oranges would start to get loud
i think the best thing is if i play in a
song you'll hear the song it will go
through in real time it will scroll
across so you'll see the
the the x-axis kind of populating
you know as time goes across and then
you'll see all the all the y-axis
filling up
with with all the different colors and
the data points that is picking out and
effectively
under the hood it's testing each hundred
millisecond millisecond slice
with a load of different frequencies
using that
clock method or something similar
however the the the fft algorithm
they've implemented is doing it
and it's just letting me know how loud
it is and actually the numbers i get
back are between zero and
two five five okay before you do i want
to avoid any imperial entanglements tell
me
the music that you're going to use is it
is it's not commercial
no it's not commercial this is all music
that is uh stuff that i own that i've
either written
or been part of with um okay
i'm looking up at youtube here so what
i've got here if you look at the screen
we're going to ignore all this stuff at
the bottom at the moment and what i've
got is i've got these five light blue
songs which are actually full
tracks i'm not going to play them all in
because for the purposes of the demo we
can use the intros of the song so i'm
just going to play a little bit of each
of them
and then here i've got 10 clips i've got
a clip of
the music recorded through my phone
so these are to emulate somebody
sampling the sound
and the the point one clip is actually
pretty much the same thing where i've
recorded it through my phone
but i'm also talking over it so try and
emulate some background noise so
so we've got two different tests there
but the first thing i have to do is play
in the raw audio to the system
the whole of this following on from our
last video the whole of this demo
i've done with javascript css and html5
as well
and i've been using the the web audio
api
the um the audio context stuff which has
a lovely analyzer that does all the fft
for you um all built in under the hood
in the browser which is wonderful
let's click on the first song and we'll
see it populate
[Music]
that's enough of that one now i've
clicked on this song because i put this
together as a demo and it's not
something where i've labeled it all up
as
an actual piece of work that's being
published when you've analyzed the song
it then appears in the list
underneath as a green button that you
can click on which we'll get to later so
effectively once i've played them all in
we're going to end up with this
this blue row here being duplicated
underneath in green and it should look
pretty much exactly the same apart from
the fact that the buttons will be green
but that means that they've all been
played in and we've got a noise
fingerprint for each one
let me play in the other ones
it's quite nice to see the base being
drawn on this one
the most interesting thing is is
obviously that song there 2020
rendezvous but there's actually a remix
of that which called wise sounds similar
similar tempo it's about 2pm bpm
difference
it's got different drum sounds but it'll
be interesting to see
how it can differentiate between
effectively the same song but in a remix
fashion but let's do the others
all right that'll do for that one next
one
2020 rundown remix last one
[Music]
okay so that will do for that one there
so what i've done is i've got all the
songs in here now and before i do the
clips because we've got a song up and
this one's particularly good on the
screen
at the moment what we're seeing here is
as you can probably see in the pixelated
chunks particularly if i
if i zoom in on it a bit you can see
these tiny little sort of hundred
millisecond slices so as you can see
we've got these hundred millisecond
slices
and then the yellow marks are where the
most prominent frequencies are and i've
effectively split this up into six
different
chunks that can actually be changed down
here if you wanted to change it you can
say maximum points per slice
and you can actually change that as one
of the variables but you can see clearly
where
like a symbol or something has been hit
where you're getting a lot of
data on each beat so you can kind of see
the tempo of the song
as it's playing through the music you
see the bass line moving i think that's
that's kind of cool but if i now play in
these clips and these are tiny clips
these are sort of like five six seconds
what you get if you were listening off
your phone so we'll just go through and
play all the clips in
[Music]
she's got my name
there we go so now what we've got is
we've got
all our five songs in and then we've got
five clips of just the song recorded
through my phone
and then you've got another five clips
where i'm clearly chatting over them
whatever
came into my mind at that particular
time which was just nonsense but i was
just emulating background noise
now the idea is is if i click on any of
these green ones here
it will then compare it to the songs the
first five
songs and we should tell how well it's
correlated and this will be the big
reveal
does it work so i'm going to click on
one let's see
and there you go you can see at the
bottom there it's correlated the first
clip to a thousand things
really well go clip two
and it's correlated to the second song
clip three
to the third song clip four to the full
tongue and clip
five oh i didn't actually i think you
missed five missed five oh
let's analyze that one
so if i do clip 5 which is now ended up
at the end there
that's actually correlating there you
can see it's correlating a bit with 20
20 rendezvous that's not a remix so
that's the same song but just different
kind of versions of it right different
version of the same song it's got the
same melody slightly different words
it's it's about 2 bpm faster so i'll
explain on the paper a minute how this
this matching happens if we go to the
other clips here so
clip 1.1 should be a thousand things
even though i'm talking
over it and then it goes down to there
to the second song
third song fourth song and then the
fifth one with me talking over it
selects the last one so he's correctly
identifying all of them
and the way we do that turn over the bit
of paper
is when we have this this set of slices
so we've got these
100 millisecond slices so we've got six
points on there and then we've got
in the next column over we'll have a
slightly
different set of points in slightly
different
places i was effectively going through
and numbering all of the points
so the first bottom most point we'll
call one
and then we'll work our way up the
column so we'll call that one two
three four five six
and then when you get to the top and
there's no more points to go you go to
the next column
and then seven eight nine and
effectively you're creating an array of
these points
but with the frequency of that it won't
exactly be the frequency it'll be the
position within the array which will be
set but it doesn't really matter the
position within the array
represents the frequency um so what
we're going to do
is we're going to take say the first
five frequencies
so all we're doing is matching the first
point
so let's say i've got this graph here
these x's
on a graph for my original song
that i'm trying to match against and
then i've got the clip that i've
recorded from my phone
and that's also got these points all i'm
trying to do is just match the first
point
if if i've got a point at 100 hertz in
my sample from my phone
and there's a point at 100 hertz in the
original song
we can then work from there if there's
not a match on that first point we can
move on
you know we don't we don't care about
that we can move on to the next next
thing
so from there we've got the noise print
that comes in now the noise print that
comes in your phone may not have
all of the same frequencies exactly the
same and you might have less top end
frequency or less bottom
frequencies so we're not trying to match
an exact pattern to the original one
what we're trying to do is pick
one anchor point and then say we want
x number of other points that were
within what i've recorded off my phone
to match within a song and it doesn't
matter if they match in the right order
as long as the frequencies are there
so in a way you could
sample um have
have more maximum points per slice
for the original song than you would off
the phone if you wanted to you could
have less data points for
the the information you're getting off
your phone for the
the quality of the microphone on say the
phone in this instance doesn't affect
the frequencies does it
it will for the absolute bottom and
absolute top end
if i play an a called on the guitar and
i recorded it into a really bad sort of
old-school dictaphone or or a really
awful
like iphone one or something that
doesn't sound good into
i don't even know whether they had a
voice notes at but let's say i did that
you're still going to be able to get out
usable information and hear that i'm
playing an a chord on a guitar
okay it's not it's not going to sound
beautiful but i mean it really does when
i play but um
it's it's still going to be a
representation of an a
chord so as long as the
prominent frequencies are there and
you've got some kind of
system to kind of match them up with the
original song it will work so
so what you end up with is you end up
with these groupings so these groupings
will be if i've numbered all my points
in my sample and i've numbered all the
points within
the original song i mean actually forget
the original song that doesn't really
matter we'll number the points within
the sample i've got from the phone
um we're gonna test we're gonna look for
point one anywhere in any of the songs
and then if we find point one we're then
gonna try and match points two three
four and five
and if we look within that hundred
millisecond slice or the next hundred
millisecond slice
because particularly with lower end
frequencies they resonate in the room so
they could last a bit longer if you were
recording in a room compared to having
the original recording
so you might look over into the next
slice and see whether the frequency is
there and obviously if your
first anchor point is actually at the
top and there are no more frequencies in
your column you've got to go to the next
column
so effectively you're you're looking for
one and then if you find it you test two
three four and five
against the original source and if you
get a match you just add one to
the match score and then you move on you
set point two as your anchor point
and you try and match three four five
and six and then you set
point three as your anchor point so what
you'd end up with is drawing
a line around that lot there
and then i'll get a red pen to do it in
a different color
and then the next one we're going to be
testing that lot there
and if i go to a green pen the next lot
i'm going to be testing
is this slot here plus
this one at the bottom of the next
column what i'm interested is the
distance
from the anchor point to the next point
and then from the distance from there to
there and the distance from there to
there and then across to there and then
across to there
and i'm happy to find say this third
point
i'm happy to find that in the next
column that would also be
a match in the next column across
because
you don't know at what point you're
taking these hundred millisecond slices
you could be slightly out of phase with
the original so
something that appeared in the same
column on one would appear across two
columns because of the timing so you
these are all the tolerances that i'd
imagine shazam
have been through and tweaked and gone
crazy on to the nth degree
all i'm really doing is just looking for
these maximum frequencies and then using
an algorithm to match them up and
it works really well and it's really
fast as well the naive approach
would be to try and match up the whole
array of all the noise print
in a five second chunk to all the other
array and effectively you get this
huge convolution going across the whole
thing it'd be like this huge convolution
filter going across the whole thing
which
you know computationally would just i
mean i i did that initially that was
that was just to check that things were
working i knew it wasn't going to be how
i ended up doing it but
um to do something with five songs that
took me
no time at all i clicked and it had
matched it even in javascript and
html5 as my as my ui um
it was taking maybe 10 15 seconds to
search one clip against five songs
with with it um doing it as an array
match whereas doing it where you
have the points and you just anchor off
the first one and you look just seem
really instantaneous and then of course
if you put those little
five point groupings or six-point
groupings and you somehow represent them
in a hash table
they'd be very very quick to look up in
a database and you could
use all sorts of uh clever computer
sciencey stuff
to make the algorithm work even faster
so
you're holding it and it just tells you
the song straight away
if you're playing on say an
old-fashioned turntable
uh my memory of these things is that
they can play at
slightly different rates and then
presumably that would affect frequencies
would it
well it would so so technically it would
but it all depends on how big your fft
bin is and how many